It's Crash and Coco! Get them!
She's annoying!
Okay, okay, okay. Now, let's battle!
Call and Makuta!
Hiya!
Super Kick!
Hey, we use Super Kick a lot. Let's use...
Ah! Hey! Bazooka!
You're Annoying!
Bazooka! Use the Howitzer!
Howitzer?
Howitzer!
Use your Bazooka!
Hiya!
Let me use that.
Bazooka!
I found the Catawg Claw!
Whatever.
Laser eyes!
Okay.
Bazooka time!
I can't squeeze my hand in it.
Look, and I can even...
I think...
Bazooka!
I guess so.
Last for a minute.
Nice trick!
Watch for Snakey.
Snakey? Is that what you named it?
You actually named a monster Snakey?
Yes, I did!
I think it's a worm.
A worm. He named a...
He named a 30-foot worm Snakey?
I mean, a 60-foot worm Snakey?
I'd put it in a museum.
I'd use a...
I think I'd just, um, pick a pinch.
I'm taking a quick rest after I kick him to bits.
I can pinch him with my Bazooka.
First stop.
A chain!
We're supposed to be annoying you.
I'm here!
I guess you want it to be the hard way.
You mean you want to battle your hardest?
The notch is a little...
Failed.
Boing!
I want a head while we're doing that.
Attacking?
I'm not using any word attacks.
Use the most powerful...
Use the most powerful attack!
It's supposed to knock her out.
It's failed.
I'm learning to be the Beam Master of the Super Family.
Just like Agent Nine was.
Uh, well he is, but I'm learning to be second in command.
Oh, Beep-Beep!
We're not those things that sprout up in your garden.
Cut off!
Join in there.
Just you and me, Makuta and Colin, Destroyer.
Hi-yah!
Rumpet Slam!
Hit me. Good thing I jumped in time.
Makuta.
These guys are pathetic losers.
Who do you call pathetic?
It's Serena.
Yup.
Attack her!
How about your favorite color?
I don't have a favorite color.
Ugh.
Attack her with the hyper beam.
Whaaaaat?
It's a hyper beam...
Oh.
Wait a second.
Tasty!
Oh, nobody makes fun of my dance!
Get in there.